in this video we'll be talking about the
anaphase promoting complex and its role
in cell cycle progression as the name
suggests it talks about anaphase
promoting right so it helps to
transition from metaphase to anaphase so
this is the cell cycle and right now we
are going to focus on the metaphase to
anaphase transition where APC or
anaphase promoting complex which is a
multi-protein complex plays an crucial
role now the APC functions at a
molecular level like a ubiqutin liase
enzyme it's a e3 ubiqutin liase enzyme
means it can attach ubiquity into
certain molecules especially
APC regulates the activity of cycline B
and
cdk1 so let let us understand why this
particular cyclan b cdk1 or mhas cycling
is important in context of cell division
so generally cyclan B cdk1 is activated
with the help of several kyes and
phosphatases for example there is V1
kyes which phosphorate and inhibit this
particular cycline there are kinases and
cdc25 phosphatases which can activate
the cycl B cdk5
cdk1 so basically this particular cycl
cdk complex regulates various aspects of
cell division like chromatin
condensation which is prerequisite for
anaphase nuclear envelope breakdown
fragmentation of Golgi spindle formation
Etc now this cycl B cdk1 is actually
ubiquity annihilated by the APC and
degraded at the end of the
metaphase question comes why it has to
be
degraded think about it this particular
cycling phosphates lamin and thereby
break down the lamin uh structure on
which the nuclear envelope is formed so
basically if this particular complex is
is active even at the end of the
anaphase then how the nuclear envelope
would reappear and there are many
reasons for which anaas promoting
complex is super important in terms of
degrading the cycline B and cdk1
activity so basically anaes promotin
complex poly ubiqutin late that and the
E3 ubiqutin lias uh
activity specifically tags these
particular complex for Destruction
cyclan B is destroyed in a proteosome
assisted pathway so once cyclan B is not
there cdk1 is inactive because it's a
cycline dependent kyese without cycline
it cannot perform its
job so its activity is
off now anaes promoting complex also
help in other aspect of anaphase let me
tell you how so during the anaphase one
of the key event is basically separation
of these chromatids they have to be
pulled apart on two opposite poles and
if there is a defective segregation that
can lead to change in the py so that is
why proper segregation of the chromosome
during anaphase is required and anaphase
promoting complex make sure the
segregation is equal so in the metaphase
all the spindle assembles onto the
overall centromeric region in the
kineticore portion now this particular
micr Tibu attachment has to be accurate
such that the tension is equal on both
the sides if the tension is equal it is
a good time to separate but there is a
potential problem before the separation
because there are specific proteins
depicted here in PR pink like condensins
which can condense the chromosome and
kind of encapsulate the chromatins like
uh basically like a bangle so these
particular this particular APC
complex prevent a inhibitor known as
securin and thereby a particular enzyme
separas which can break down this
condensing ring is activated so once APC
inhibits and degrade securin separas is
activated and thereby the condensing
rings are broken down and the proper
segregation can happen in the anaphase
so now we understood what really happens
in normal scenario in the late and uh
late metaphase and the anaphase
beginning now things can go wrong for
example there is an unequal tension
right there could be a situation where
there is unequal tension on one side of
the uh centromere in this context if the
chromosomes are pulled apart maybe the
segregation won't be equal there could
be a problem in chromosomal Ploy that is
why these condensing rings has to be
fixed at their own place so that is
achieved by
inhibiting the APC complex and there are
several kyes which can sense this
unequal tension and convey this message
to the APC and thereby when APC activity
is prevented securin is not degraded
anymore and separas activity is
negligible thereby the chromosomes
separation cannot occur or cannot
initiate this process is not
initiated and then
the microtubule assembly is reorganized
and until the particular tension is
balanced so this is another important
factor which APC contributes to now APC
degrades the cyclan B cdk1 complex and
that is super important for replication
try to understand how because
replication initiation complex has to
associate and assemble to the DNA on The
Late G1 phase and in the the S phase the
replication bubble would form now there
are two components cdt1 and cd6 which
are essential for these helas to be
loaded and start the bubble formation
now these particular components once
phosphorilated cannot reassemble so
let's say one particular division round
is gone and then they have to reassemble
again into the DNA to start the next
cycle of the division right but the
problem is until and unless they are def
phosphorilated ated they cannot
reassemble but who keeps them in a
phosphorilated state it's the cycline B
cdk one complex which keep them in a
phosphorilated state now it's not bad
thing this kind of phosphorilation which
is inhibitory in nature ensures that the
replication doesn't start in the G2 or M
phase which is crucial but after the
point of time this particular cycl B
cdk1 activity is gone because it is
degraded by APC
and that was crucial again because if
this degradation doesn't happen then
these phosphor this phosphorilated
proteins cannot be un phosphorilated and
they cannot reassemble but since there
is nobody to phosphorate them and
phosphatase activity is there thereby
cdt1 and cdc6 are un phosphorilated and
they can reassemble on the orc and start
another round of replication in the next
stage of the cell cycle thereby ANF is
promoting complex is important in
context of various aspect of cell
division so I hope this video was useful
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up you can get more notes and
flash card in our Facebook page link uh
links are provided in the description
see you in next video support our
Channel using super thanks you can pay
via PTM PayPal or up
IU